[Applause]
look
i don't know how i keep conning
legendary people into doing this podcast
i have no idea but today we have
am i allowed to just call you the best
chef in the world yeah haven't you
gotten that
that those are the kind of awards you
get they're just like best chef
ever
like you look down your list of awards
and it's just like the greatest chef who
ever lived like like i
you know how else
i've been very lucky i've been very
lucky
when i i listen to you on another
podcast and and if someone that has
followed your
career uh and
you know is a dork i'm a i'm a
the way that a lot of people fan out
when they meet a comedian or a musician
or i geek out with chefs like people at
the time at the top of their field so
like i get starstruck when i meet you
know i'm around someone like you
uh so i'm going to be like nervous and
flub but it is kind of hilarious to like
is someone that's been a fan for selling
to look at your credits and it's just
like oh yeah
uh you know
the best chef in the united states award
food and wine you know stuff like it's
like is that a trip to hear that and
also i know you aren't lucky
it's very sweet to say that but you have
like worked your ass off and i heard you
talking on a podcast about it's like
there's no shortcuts even today i work
seven days a week like
you know being a chef is one of those
careers that i feel like
is very similar to stand up and that you
work at night you're under a tremendous
amount of pressure
what worked last night might not be what
works tonight
you have a whole plan and the second
something happens that plans out the
window and you're you have to be
prepared for 50 things to go wrong
and then
uh
to execute the plan you had and then to
throw it all out the window and then
improvise and then have be able to have
grace
and be able to communicate super
directly with everyone going like the
plan changed
and
be a boss without being bossy
it's weird being a leader without
pissing people off and then you work
till four in the morning yeah and your
job is never done because all day every
day is like oh what's this new vegetable
like you can't like as a comedian
when i walk through the world it's just
like oh is that a joke is that funny oh
what's funny about trashcan like i can't
ever turn it off i imagine you just move
through the world and it's like what's
that tomato everything yeah everything
and the same with restaurants and being
a chef and
doing comedy
your material has to change
right
and
you have
just like the audience in a show
you don't know how they're
gonna react so
same for us like we have a hundred
guests at the restaurant
every night we have 30 chefs in the
kitchen
so there's always human error right
there's always a little bit of
inconsistency
and then you always have a hundred
different pallets in the dining room
and you get through all that
and the next day you do it all over
again which is like live comedy it's
like you know
yeah it's like it's it's you know
literal and figurative it's about taste
it's like you know you have some people
that like are gonna get the joke not
gonna get the joke they're gonna be
offended by the joke triggered by the
joke some people you know say idea of
having that real time feedback i think
that someone tasting food is very
similar to someone uh hearing a joke
live because it's an involuntary
reaction they can't really fake it right
you you know what i'm saying it's one of
those things where it's like
you gotta you gotta
it's not like a broadway play or music
where you put it out and someone's
listening to their home in their house
you don't know what their reaction is
but this is live and when you're on
sewer right you have you're in different
cities and those posters react
differently i that happened to us we did
um
a pop-up in madrid
so we certainly needed some madrid for a
month and it's just the pilot service
it's very different really just
everything seasoning everything and so
when you do a pop-up why why do you
choose madrid like if you could choose
anywhere i'm just curious like i love
spain just to go there and yeah i love
spain and a lot of our uh team had never
been to europe
they were young they've just never been
yeah like they had their past forces and
then how do you know like when like so
as a comedian when i go to you know
state to state city to city or touring
scandinavia people will say like they
might not get that here right right when
do you go you know what that's a note
worth taking or no i'm gonna do what i
do
and i'm not gonna change what i do
because of a different taste when is it
like i'm honoring this palette or is it
like no i'm doing what i do
we when we went to sleep we took their
indigenous ingredients and some of their
techniques and we already fired them
yeah so they put them through our lens
you turn them into a balloon yeah sort
of yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um and so i just really quick want to
say i usually start this podcast asking
someone are we friends like how do we
know each other so everyone sort of like
knows i'm gonna throw that to you okay
sure was it 20 years ago that we met it
was
not 20. the first basically job i got
that paid me any money
as a comedian was lexus hired me to do a
talk show in their new cars
and i like went to ten cities and
interviewed like the most you know
influential people in music
you know culture
you know chef in each city and i got to
interview you yeah in a little car that
was right
okay so yeah you're gonna you're just
gonna go
drive
i'm grant hacketts the chef owner of a
linear restaurant chicago normally
comedians come out of like just bad
childhoods that's basically right how
weak that's what chefs do too that's why
i'm asking like how what's the common
denominator and the people that become
chefs what is it oh
careful sorry wow that was
hardcore that i must have been a
nightmare that was great we had a lot of
fun
you know and i remember you know then
you had already talked about what
happened you know with your
you know the the health issue but i just
i
as someone that i never want to ask
something that anyone else has asked in
an interview or that you've asked talked
about so much right but now i feel the
need to talk about it again is you know
uh correct me if i'm wrong you were
diagnosed with tongue cancer yeah uh
they said we're gonna have to cut out 75
of it yep you said no i'm going to get
some second opinions you found this
incredible person yep and then you
lost
your taste from the chemo and then got
it back right for a year it was gone
already already amazing but i want to
just revisit that again because after
covid all of a sudden you know that's a
story that's already wild because like a
chef lost a sense of yeah yeah at what
point are you like
all right god i get i get where you're
like
did it have anything to do with being a
chef in taste like
or was that just a total
crazy coincidence crazy for instance
never
no risk factors no that's like it's a
comedian you're getting cancer in my
wrist right hold the microphone right
never smoked never drink heavily never
you know no nothing
no it's heavy kind of
hpv they had no idea where it came from
and so now
i feel like it's worth revisiting that
and talking to you because you know the
big thing about kovad was you lose your
taste yeah
and there was this
huge zeitgeist thing
where
all of a sudden there was a whole new
yeah appreciation for your tastes right
i guess people don't realize we've all
probably had the flu and you know you're
eating you're tripping soup you can't
taste it right
the phobia's name really brought it to
the forefront
um i apparently never had a little bit
really i
i feel like karmically you played your
dues in the department
right
yeah so you know was it weird to hear
people complaining about that afterwards
through yeah
no no i was supposed to i mean you have
no motivation to eat
right yeah even though you have to do it
survive
if you can't taste it's just like that
but there's also something
you know
miraculous that happens when you lose
one cent so i had cove and i lost
both basically most of my
brain you guys saw the podcast over the
pandemic i got like the brain fog and i
couldn't remember things i i lost my
taste and smell but it is kind of
amazing
the like did you find there was any
magic in the other senses that got
stronger as you lacked that and were
building up i definitely paid attention
to the other senses to make up for it
yeah i don't know that they got
heightened i just paid attention to them
you know so interesting i would listen
to food
sounds a little weird wow yeah
i know but you know i've spent my whole
life cooking so when you put something
in a saute pan yeah
i know by the way the oil is popping if
the pan's hot enough if it's ready to be
flipped if it you know
so you really start paying attention to
that stuff
i'm obsessed with the wisdom that only
comes with age and experience yeah in a
time where kind of
anyone can
do a funny video and tick-tock and call
themselves a comedian anyone can take a
picture of a pretty avocado toast and
say they're a chef like you know i think
that people like you and i that have put
in like the 10 000 hours and like
you know um
you know worked so hard
to a point to where it's like you know
you have this additional skill
that is your intuition and your instinct
and things you just can't teach someone
that's just starting out you can't teach
someone this is when the oil is the
hottest one it's just you have to have
put in that 10 000 hours
like you know
what are you seeing with new people
coming in and i'm not saying an
entitlement but there's a certain thing
i see with jobs like this where i'll see
a comedian come in and they're like well
where's my special i've been doing this
for two years and you're like yeah i
promise you
you think you're ready but some when
when you're really ready is when you're
able to do that
when everything goes wrong yeah
if you can't do this with the microphone
going out with a drunk person going fuck
you exactly yeah you know
i
the instant verification now that
everybody is fast it's just it's hard to
deal with
but i also don't want to sound like a
dinosaur and i also feel like
posteriorly like we have to
move on like you know i used to work 16
17 hours a day
i don't think people should
i had to
uh to succeed
but now people just
i'm going to generalize
most of the younger people that we have
come in the kitchen they want to work
eight hours a day and be a chef like the
first year that they're associated and
it just doesn't work that way it's just
not possible yeah you have to
you have to learn the basics you have to
pay your lose a bit and i for me uh like
i'm always you know torn between going
like yes i probably did it an
unnecessarily hard way there are
probably some ways that can be easier
but i'm already like you already have it
you have social media now you already
you have youtube you compare like
those are those are shortcuts that are
like okay no that's just progress but
there's certain stuff that's like if you
really want to be a great comedian if
you want to really want to be a
a great writer performer you're going to
have to put up in that ten thousand
hours and um
it's hard to convince some younger
people that these days
but man am i glad that i did it
i don't know like you say as you get
older you get wiser right had i been as
wise as i am now back then
i wouldn't i wouldn't be where i am now
and sometimes the wisdom doesn't come
you know consciously it's like
when shit hits the fan yeah and you're
able to improvise and know exactly what
to do like that's when it comes in you
know so i'm just curious like you know
what have you learned as a boss being in
charge of so many people yeah and having
to be in charge be an authority figure
but still
you know people want to feel invested
and they don't want you know it's this
weird time where i feel like being a
boss i don't want to i want to be a boss
without being bossy
you're under so much pressure i'm always
so impressed by chefs because you have
to yell out all these orders without
people feeling like you're yelling at
them right right we had a young
culinarian about two weeks ago that
decided to quit
just walked out okay and when it charges
the interview the exit interview with
him uh the reason was because when i
walked into the restaurant
i don't say hello to every single person
and so but if you did you get sued for
sexual harassment perhaps i don't know
or i like why someone saying hello to me
the first hour of my day would be saying
hello to everyone and it's just a weird
balance that you're saying but what i
really miss is
i miss the immaturity
like i miss that feeling of 15 years ago
i miss that wrongness i miss
not knowing if it's going to work
so the maturity that i have now
i can go into the kitchen and just sort
of
i just know
it's gonna work
it's not that exciting it really is
about that adrenaline isn't it of like
the pressure of and discovery mm-hmm
like how cool is it when you write
something new and you're like this is
really fresh
right and same for me
it what what is the next balloon what is
the next table top dessert
those only come around every so often
you know and when they do it's special
have you noticed that there's any kind
of like this i was you know just
thinking about you know again how close
being a chef is to being a comedian
and i was like okay these days sort of
the big challenges comedian is you can't
say this word and this is punching down
and people like you know largely that's
it's cancer culture's not real most
comedy fans don't want safe comedy but
there has been an evolution of like yeah
we're not doing fat chicks jokes we're
not saying the n word or tranny like
there's certain things like that was a
necessary evolution
but i was thinking about yours and i was
like i wonder what it would be now and i
was like oh is it like allergies
like this
gluten and peanut allergies like do you
find yourself being like oh i have my
hands tied
yeah a bit but that that's always been
there oh okay yeah it's always been
there i you know i think it really is
the people that are
working now it's just hard to
with the cultural shift and the the
re-prioritization of worldwide balance
it it has really flipped the whole model
of running a restaurant at
at that level
you know where it was always so
demanding and so stressful
and even i mean the the cliche of
lauren ramsey like swearing and throwing
a pan and
like now that's like a toxic working oh
yeah there's none of that so we've
really had to change in the last five
years a lot with our management style
and
expectations and
it's really getting short the food's
always cold uh because we're not allowed
to brush it right
but you know that that is really
heartbreaking for me to hear because
it's like you know if you're signing up
to be mentored by and to work under
someone that
is it's just frustrating that it's it's
not like you know i'm going to give this
person the benefit of the doubt that
this is a management style that has
worked and been efficient and it's not
personal do you know what i'm saying
saying we got to get this movement it's
like no one's attacking you and i want
you you know
and knowing the difference if someone is
truly being emotionally abusive that's
different than someone just being a boss
who's like in a rush you know so it's
like
it is a really tough balance but it it
really it is frustrating when i hear
someone like you who i know has such a
great heart and i know would never
intentionally be sadistic right like you
don't get off of me statistic but you
just want to get it done and you know
and i think it really when when
when this stuff happens it robs the next
generation of learning
you know some effective ways to get you
done quickly it's a thing don't become a
chef if you don't want to
be in the chaos of like right let's move
how you open the stand so to you like
what excites you like in terms of like
you know i was listening to you talk
about you know there's a couple
restaurants in la you like
actually really like like what
like for me if i'm gonna go see comedy
it's sort of like oh god it's like feels
like work like what excites you in the
food world right now
well please don't say sourdough
it won't be sour though
so you know obviously for me it's still
about
discovery i want to see new stuff i
would love
i'm almost 48 years old
so i would love for
the next
27 year olds to come out of nowhere and
just blow the doors off of everyone
because i want to eat that restaurant
yeah
i want to even if i can't produce it
like i used to
where it's all fresh and new all the
time
i still want to experience it no you
know
there was a restaurant there is a
restaurant here in l.a that is what is
that
and is that the one in culver city
yeah vespers vesper teen yeah
and so
you know i am a little bit biased
because he worked for me for a bit but
uh the meal that i had there was like
it was
case in point if you work for me and
don't go to hr you will amazing
restaurants right suck it up but you
know it was that it was that
probably only three times in my life
have i felt like i was on mars
nothing was familiar
everything was new exciting like that's
that's cool that's pretty surreal yeah
and then so this is
an odd question i know but to me you
know working in restaurants uh you know
being a waitress working in
places where you are uh entertaining
people
i feel like you're uniquely qualified to
have some observations about like human
nature yeah like what have you learned
about you know as someone that crafts
surprises for people you create those
holy shit moments those
moments yep you know the art of service
and feeding someone is such an intimate
yeah
for sure thinking is there anything so
personal right is like in the difference
between
waiting
20 minutes for a meal versus 30. like
if people are waiting on it does it make
it like i'm just curious if there's any
rules and things you would know that
oh man there's a bunch but one thing i
know is that people that come to arenas
steal a lot of stuff
they're very rude
right so you i mean what is an expensive
restaurant and then you have to wait
like three months to get in maybe people
feel entitled so apparently they have to
take like the votive out of the bathroom
and put it in their purse or they have
to
we had recently when we reopened after
the pandemic
uh randomly had a fedex envelope in the
mail addressed to me
no return address opened it up there was
an millennia embroidered naption
and a spoon
and there was a handwritten note and it
was just i'm sorry i felt bad when i got
home here's your nephew and swim back
why would someone steal a spoon what are
you gonna do with one spoon
seriously
and this happens all the time
all the time anyway that's not
necessarily what i learned but
maybe
here's the thing about that as someone
that i feel like when i was 21 would do
some shit like that
it's like it you know
having a spoon for millennia is really
cool until you tell someone you stole it
yeah if you're like grant gave this to
me right it's the coolest thing to have
every morning you wake up and you have
cereal with no money
holy shit you have an olympia spoon yeah
where she and then how'd you get it it's
like why stolen like you're an asshole i
feel like he told a couple people about
it for sure yeah shame them they had to
send it back
or had too much wine like whatever
because it's like
someone that totally loves shit like
that not from a restaurant like one of
my favorite things to do at christmas
parties is steal an ornament okay and
then give it to the person for christmas
the following year they know
right now
you take like an ornament off their tree
put in your purse and then for christmas
next year wrap it up and give it to them
what's the reaction it's just a funny
where people are like what it's just a
dumb stupid thing
and a lot of times
it's like for my friends that just like
have you know have fancy shit yeah and
they'll be like thank you so much i love
this this is gorgeous like it's yours
yeah they don't even know you don't even
know so it's just like a funny dumb
stupid prank but that's just
but that's fascinating but like the idea
of like the lighting in the bathroom so
lighting it like you have it down to
such an art and a science it makes such
a big difference it's like you know as a
comedian it's like the tiniest thing a
light being too light the spotlight not
being perfect the music stopping too
soon as soon as
someone in the experience
has an idea that the experience was
curated to not manipulate them but but
it is though there's an awkward when you
hear a spoon drop when you hear a thing
break all of a sudden it breaks the
magic spell you're under yeah like what
are some mistakes that people make in
restaurants like with lighting with
plates with
servant with
they don't
um
what everyone has to understand is you
have again you have a hundred
people in there that all have a
different opinion yep right
so if you
control an environment
you have to explain it invigorates
does that make sense kind of
so
rather than force your
opinion on them
and
try to tell them how to eat or tell them
what their
what they like
you have to
tell the story
to make them believe
that they like it
of course
you know what i mean yes so
you have to think it's your idea it can
you can't feel manipulated so it's it's
like a hand very handy
to feel like it's hand
hands-on so it feels hands-on right
and that
it's just a lot of practice
it's a big deal i mean it's like when i
go into a you know stand-up show and if
i'm running a little bit late and the
music's already playing in the house
and it's not loud enough i'm like
i don't want to come off like a bitch
but it has to be
20 percent louder or people are hearing
other people chew gum if there's a
decibel level that makes people go i'm
about to party instead of like i'm
waiting for a show yeah you know and it
makes such a big difference and it's
something you can only sort of
know if you've been doing it a long time
and have
been burned and seen how it fucks
everything up like if i go on stage and
the l in the
first six rows are all totally lit i'm
like fuck why
because it's it's basically you know
well now with masks completely
completely dark
pretty much the mass mandate is done
right now but if people see other people
in masks or not in mass or it's
distracting for someone that's watching
because if you can see the person next
to you you're like what why are you
doing that why are you talking so much
why is your back like you want to sort
of make it as dark as possible
especially when you're doing edgy
materials so no one feels like they're
in trouble if they laugh
and the more lit they are the more
on display they are also someone that
talks to the audience and kind of can
like
they're kind of like when is she going
to call on me yeah am i in trouble you
know so you want them to feel like
they're completely anonymous and totally
in the dark
and
that's funny because in the restaurant
it's sort of the opposite where
obviously everybody wants to look
beautiful right yep and for the longest
time
the only thing that i feared about was
the food
so when we first built the restaurant we
had pin lights coming down and hitting
the table right where the plate bear
would go
but everybody looked terrible yeah
because the light was from above yep and
you would have the shadows yeah everyone
looks like steve buscemi yeah yeah right
so you know we had to install mid light
and once we did um it changed the
atmosphere in the restaurant people felt
more confident they were happier
i assume that they assume that they look
better you know
weird stuff like that because you know
covet has changed you know the live
business dramatically you know in terms
of
sorry
a puppy that is just very needy um so
uh you know
it's changed live business in a lot of
ways you know comedians we can adapt
because there's nothing we can't kind of
joke about you know
you know the idea of people coming to
sit shoulder to shoulder you know in the
dark with other strangers and exhale
droplets like of course we were going to
have to make some changes is there
anything in the restaurant business
whether it's like the menu being on the
barcode or anything like that that
you're just like oh we have to go back
to the way it was before because it
killed some of the magic i mean
everything yeah
yeah heating and masks yeah i mean
imagine edible masks
yeah
but yeah i mean we give you a mask and
you just slowly eat it off right
uh
yeah everything we i mean from the from
the perspective of the staff
imagine being in a hot kitchen for 12 14
hours with this thing on your face
nightmare oh nightmare but even the way
that um we had to space everyone out
that dramatically changed the atmosphere
in the restaurant
you know if if now all of a sudden
you're
six eight feet apart from everyone else
you feel isolated yeah and there's no
energy and there's you know it's just
very different especially at uh uh you
know restaurants like yours next and
elenia where like when you see someone
else getting their food you're like
what's that oh my god it's like there's
none of that right
i mean i was coming back but it was
weird
it felt sterile and then was it like i
guess it was supposed to feel sad
so maybe we were doing the right thing
and like the because well elinia is sort
of you you you get all these corset but
like
just the magic of holding up a menu
that's not on your phone you know what i
mean like i missed that i always say
that through our phone's name always is
that going to go away or does that have
to stay forever i never been around i
think people like to be able to have it
with them
but by the time i do it i'm like on my
phone and i get a text and now i feel
like i'm on my phone i know
and there's something that that piece of
paper or whatever it is
there's
the ability to be
creative with that make it part of the
experience the way it's
the paper it's on the way the font the
everything about it you know and
because we look at our phones all day by
the time it's like getting a menu at a
beautiful restaurant like this you're
like you either open it up or there's
just this like
like i feel like a princess for the
night i love the giant menu me too right
you just hide behind it yes it's a ba i
just i i didn't realize how much of a
part of that the experience of a dining
experience was until i'm like taking out
the qr code i'm like it's not working
wait do you have wi-fi where and you're
just like oh god the last menu before
the pandemic we actually took it
kind of to the extreme where you had to
uh it was a
a word search
so you had this card filled with letters
we gave everybody a pencil
and the items on the menu that they were
about to receive would be embedded in
the word search and they're the surf one
that is yeah
is there anything that you've done that
was incredibly exciting most of you know
you're legendary i've got the olynya
coffee table book right here it's like
my porn uh but all these incredible
things that you've done hot potato cold
potato the bubble gum that just the wild
magic tricks that you've done with you
know your
molecular gastronomy is there anything
that like
went wrong
solely because of a human nature thing
yeah there's one that jumps out to me
right away
we
created a special service piece
that's in the book actually
that
suspended the food
about 14 inches off the table surface on
a long wire
so there's a single bite on a wire
and you were instructed to lean forward
and eat the bite off the wire without
using your hands
so
you can imagine
depending on who you were yeah
most of the guys wouldn't touch it
the men
yeah
because it felt just embarrassing yeah
and
sexual is a little bit fat like maybe
yeah it's there's something about that
yeah
so you would have people that would
love it
and burst something laughter and that
was the point yeah yeah
to be a little awkward
that were just completely offended and
just push it away guys are like i'm not
gonna suck a dick you're just like why
yeah and so again like you absolutely
can't please everyone that's so
fascinating to me yeah
so those social experiments are a lot of
fun because food you know people
i mean we all eat three times a day or
more right and you're so
it's so personal and you're so
accustomed to
your preferences
on flavor
even the utensils that you use and stuff
like that
so to
present someone with something that's
outside of their comfort zone yeah
it's fun we're going to take a little
break from me having a crush on grant to
talk about ritual ritual is going to be
talked about by grace ritual has a new
product it's called synbiotic plus it's
here and it's amazing it's sinfully good
um and it's actually more than a
probiotic if you guys can believe it how
do you know it's good are you chewing it
up and no i'm snorting it and that's why
i'm acting like this and that's why i
look so beautiful today is because it's
just like spraying it on my vent it's a
three in one with clinically studied
prebiotics probiotics and postbiotics to
support a balanced gut microbiome one
daily capsule all of that is in one
simple daily please don't talk to anyone
you date like this streamline you think
i date people streamline gut support and
does not require refrigeration oh my god
it's just all in one because i can't
handle anything else no no no no no more
than one
symbiotic plus and ritual are here to
celebrate your
eyes not because emily wants to swallow
it's just everything gives both of these
two diarrhea so that's the only reason
they don't swallow symbiotic plus and
ritual are here to celebrate not hide
your insides there's no more shame in
your gut game
i have lives right now there has been no
shame in either of their gut game that's
why ritual is offering our listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com whitney to start ritual or
add symbiotic plus to your subscription
today stop being a silly goose take
ritual if you don't you're going to have
bad
karma
good segway um i want a new credit card
but not sure how to choose why are you
reading it like a weirdo i'm reading it
naturally why are you doing a rhetorical
question well it's are you not sure how
to choose i i mean clearly
clearly if they're listening to this
podcast they can't choose a credit card
which is why they chose us because we
are talking directly to the people that
are wishy-washy about their credit card
credit cards can be a racket uh
and uh yes i did just miss the uh
sure thing on the chair
take me seriously when it comes to
credit i know my ship credit karma uses
your credit profile to show you offers
that are tailored to your financial
situation in a jam
it'll show you the cheapest brand
of jam
credit karma partners with a wide range
of card issuers so you can be sure that
you're exploring all sorts of options
the same way you should be doing in your
dating life and your marriage ready to
find the card for you head to credit
karma with the k and check out your
personalized mix of offers today
go to creditkarma.com or the credit
karma app if you're like a grace type of
person
go to the app
to find the card for you or go to
creditkarma.com find a credit card to
buy a new phone because your phone's out
of storage you can't download any apps
so just give yourself if you wanted to
we don't have wi-fi here
that's
creditkarma.com whitney
do you have any
are you going anywhere soon are you
traveling are you gonna are you racking
up
i am i am childless and that is not
changing any time except for the two of
us don't panic i have my stand-up
special taping may 13th and 14th and
if you if you do that during the taping
you will be asked to leave and this is a
newer shape this is in newark new jersey
street if you were asked to leave
you might rush
home yeah oh yeah
jesus
victoria theater at the nj pack is where
i'm gonna be uh may 20th i'll be at
tyson's corner virginia at the capital
one hall as you all may know my mom used
to work at tyson's corner i used to go
hang out there after school not one
creep talk to me ah i'm so sorry it's
like when i was in the elevator
and he told me emily was in an elevator
with harvey weinstein her fly was open
and he told her he did look down
i think it was because it was like
protruding out like it was obvious
i thought a pussy no like the the you
know when you're flying yeah because you
wear those like like my yeah hip huggers
may 21st whitney will be in huntington
new york at the paramount what brand of
jeans are you like don't say cashmere
cupcakes cashmere cup you love saying
cashmere i know because you i laugh
every time but i don't know what that is
cupcakes cashmere is so funny what is
such a good job what is it
because it's so real
but like it's just like such a niche
brand that's like only on revolve
actually it is a walking cupcakes and
cashmere grace has a tweety bird coming
out of her pocket
she's put on today
that bears her midriff and i'm
passionate
oh my gosh
because it's sweetie bird
where are you gonna be june 24th and on
june 24th i'm going to be in calgary uh
at prince prince's island park uh
i have so many thoughts about that uh
june 26th i'll be in toronto ontario at
the danforth music hall and then i have
some rescheduled shows
because of many reasons uh september 8th
i'll be in cincinnati ohio i'll be at
the taft theater i'll actually be
performing this time instead of just
getting to the hotel at 10 pm like for
no reason at all september 9th i'll be
in philadelphia pennsylvania i'll be at
the merriam theater you guys know i went
to college in philadelphia so if you
were one of my professors i had a crush
on it's legal now
i was legal then too but
you had standards yeah yeah exactly but
you were married
on september 10 i was boring september
10th i'll be in richmond virginia at the
national september 24th i'll be in
charlottesville virginia at the
paramount theater uh you're going to
love it can't wait back to my hero
grant who i feel like i'm making very
uncomfortable with all my stuttering
and awkwardness
so let me ask you as someone who you
know i did text you earlier full
disclosure i was like what do we serve
grant to eat and drink this is my
nightmare
what
on a daily basis like as like the past
with your health like what on a daily
basis i'm just curious when you're like
you're like i'll just have oreos or
whatever it was do you consciously you
know think about your health now that
you're in remission and free and clear
yeah because i mean there is so much
science coming out and obviously food
matters when you put your body matters
but it's also about how you feel about
the food sometimes
you know if we're really stressed out
about eating the right thing yeah that's
actually worse for you than eating the
quote-unquote unhealthy thing right
where are you in that
i'm not particularly healthy
um
i would probably lean more towards
mentally make myself
feel good
physically
i mean look our grip my grandfather ate
mcdonald's every day for 50 years like i
didn't live until he was you know sure
you know it
i'm also a chef that we're still a
tremendous amount so
i rarely sit down for a meal during the
day
if i eat it's probably standing up and
it's really fast
and it's something that we prepare the
whole staff meal you know and
so you know i love pasta and i love
ice cream and rich crackers and you know
i don't i don't
that's
people have this notion that
because i'm a chef clicking on this like
food that i play with tweezers that i go
home and do that yeah yeah that's insane
right
i go home and have a little cereal or
something what kind of cereal do you eat
well
i i like some food cereal too like
cinnamon sauce crunch dude that's my
shit
apple jacks apple jacks yeah
i love the sweet stuff peanut butter cap
and crunch peanut i love peanut butter i
will eat peanut butter i have a job with
a spoon all day in front of the entire
staff
and they're just like what what
you know it's what peanut butter
that is so fascinating to me um
and then is there something where
do you ever feel like
i've been doing this for so long
when am i going to be able to just work
kind of less hard like like the idea of
it's like
i mean when am i going to be able to
just like is this going to run on its
own without me having to
have you just learned you know what
you know
the more successful i get the more i
realize
i'm actually gonna have to work harder
and harder because the bar gets higher
and higher and you always have to be
there to set the target and maintain
quality control even though there's this
little thing in the back your mind is
like i put in all these hours like when
am i gonna like be able to just phone it
in and it'll run on its own
so the truth is
it's not
what i physically do
it is my
presence in the restaurant
and that goes on
the employee side and the guest side
so imagine if
i don't know you go to a youtube concert
you sit down you're all excited
instead of walking up some other dude
walks up and you're like well this this
ain't sucked yeah right yeah that
happens on the vest side all the time if
they know that i'm not in the restaurant
mentally
it's already not going to be a good
the truth of the matter is it would
probably be better
at times
the stream is really tight
and
you know some of the people that we have
there have been there 15 years how would
it be better if you weren't there
just trying hard they wouldn't be all
grumpy that you didn't say hi when you
came in maybe
maybe that no they have something to
prove
yeah they have something to prove and
and they will they would love nothing
more than
to
have somebody come in and then write me
an email and say holy crap that was
amazing because that makes them feel
good
you know it is it is a tough one we need
to get you this is my robot we need to
get you a robot that can just be in the
back and they think you're there
because also
you know just there's taste is so
personal i mean just
you know i'm fascinated by it's like i'm
i'm a black licorice bitch uh yeah i'm a
black licorice bitch i know that is the
hottest take i've ever had that is the
most polarizing thing it really is you
can say
and like you know i have a friend that
cilantro tastes really bad to her like
there's some is it cilantro yeah that's
a generous thing in this it's a it's a
genetic thing right isn't it we've been
evolved to
you know recoil at certain flavors based
on where you
are from probably say soapy to her it's
like she's like this so yeah and then so
i'm always curious like do you have you
gleaned any uh like insight on what's
nature and what's nurture with people
and they're like emotional reactions to
food
i mean i certainly have them mm-hmm i i
there's food that i don't like like what
seriously sea urchin yeah yeah that's
fair i don't like it but if you didn't
know what it looked like would you like
it
does that make sense like how much of
what something looks like affects
or where it comes from there's a lot of
men like we we have people from the
restaurant and they're like
probably everything but no
doubts ducks yeah yeah why why'd that
well i had a pet duck when i was growing
up or a rabbit or something
um
yeah
not so much how it looks like with the
person it's it's there's just something
there's something fascinating to me
about like what you were just saying
when you're like when one sense is taken
away like just think of someone if they
had their vision taken away like you
know how how much is uh tastes like
psychological and fascinated by there's
a restaurant in copenhagen that um
is very theatrical and they what's
called it's uh elves right oh okay
and so they they
they'll they'll serve you a beef force
and they'll play a video of
the animal being slaughtered
and they're
i know
but they're trying to
they're trying to promote like
sustainability and all that sort of
stuff but they also want you to know
where the food comes from
because they feel like people take that
for granted right
i know
probably not for me yeah i i thought you
were going to say noma
yeah that's the one that you know is
because
yeah no my i went when i performed in
copenhagen and you know and there was
like all this like moss around some in
there i remember going like psych i know
this is an incredible meal because it's
at noma but i remember going like moss
like yeah grow like that gives me a
little bit of an eerie feeling you know
eating ants totally yeah
yep what do you make of this are you
gonna uh i was just at this like tech
sort of conferency thing and everyone's
like you know the next thing is cricket
crickets we're eating crickets
where are you only eating bugs yeah
fruits have been popular in mexico for a
long time
and if you're if you have a
root in the towers they make flower out
for its like is there any new thing that
you're like you have a frisson
really sure
fascinating i'm just fascinated by like
the new stuff that's coming along so
it's like you know the the you know uh
meat-free meat stuff what are you like
i'm excited about this and this is a new
challenge and what do you like i'm not
fucking doing that
i
we don't use it as a restaurant um
i think we should probably pay attention
to it if if in fact we can prove that
it is beneficial to the environment
a lot of that stuff is
some of those alternatives aren't i feel
like that's true you know and also in
your body too like some of the the
meat substitutes have a lot of
sugars in them a lot of different types
of sugars and a lot of soy products
the best for you yeah soy has a lot like
gmos and stuff yeah i mean it's this
tricky thing where you know it was
reading about um you know quinoa being
like oh quinoa it's like super food and
then you find out that the country that
is providing the quinoa is like getting
fucked by an obsession with quinoa or
like we're all doing almond milk now
that's that's healthier and less
chemicals and antibiotics and then
you're like oh that's causing the
drought in california
so it's like one solution causes another
problem which is so frustrating i think
most of the time this yeah but just in
in general that's just kind of a
fascinating um you know thing to me when
i think of you know comedians right now
and how we're having to course correct
and adapt to this new cultural climate
i'm always curious what a chef like you
is like you know what to adapt to um
well really
now it's appropriation right so yes
has always been known for
influences from all over the world right
you might sit down and have a 15 course
meal
one of them be rooted in thailand and
then you might go to peru and then you
might be in france and
so we've kind of pulled all that in
but now
people are saying well you probably
shouldn't
mexican food
so it makes it a little bit you know in
the same way that you have to
perhaps adjust or or your rep as far as
now yep has to be you know yeah mess
with us and just in the way like you
know if i'm gonna
you know
if you're gonna wear uh you know i just
happen to have something right here um a
turquoise or something that has come you
know is is derivative like native
american jewelry or something which i
wear a lot of it's just a matter of
buying it from a native american artist
and not
a non-native american person
selling something that in getting credit
for but that in food that is so wild to
me because to me that's just like
the key to a lot of influence is making
some new thing and and when are you
paying homage to something and
celebrating and when you appropriate it
which is you know emily and i talk about
all the time because
i'm always like stepping in shit with
what i said of like i say chinese finger
trap it's like you're not i'm like well
then am i not gonna say french fries am
i not allowed to say mexican standoff
when or is it is french fries
appropriating french but when does it
start and when does it stop and who
makes the rules yeah and french fries
were invented in belgium so
who knows what's going on there totally
totally and like when do you go
yes okay that makes sense and when you
go like no that's not that's too fun you
know because it's our job sometimes to
go like
that's too far we have to edit
but
i mean we're still doing all those
cuisines out of money yeah
so i guess i'm not editing too hard
right right um
but you know i i feel like
we have to have we have to
make sure that we maintain our creative
freedom right as long as we don't
overly offend someone because it's also
for me food is to me the biggest
shortcut
of
understanding and developing a
connection to
a culture
a group of people that you normally
wouldn't know or understand or whatever
you know what i'm saying it's like you
know
it's such a big part of
uh empathizing and understanding
different cultures and a lot of that is
my interpretation through travel or
friends that i know or stuff you know
stuff like that so i feel like
we we have a narrative we have a story
that we're telling and
i feel as long as we're
sensitive
yeah and respectful yeah it's about a
reverence
yeah have you seen actually this is i
don't want to like look this has already
been a huge article like i'm not you
know destroying this person's business
or anything they already you know dug
their grave but just this
you know the young people that are like
i've been doing this for two years i can
open a restaurant i have a trust fund
did you hear the story about the um
restaurant squirrel in l.a
where
she was doing she was doing these like
jams and preserves oh yeah yeah that was
so full of mold people were getting
seconds
yeah
which was like is that something that
you see that is like for all these
people like i deserve this in two years
where you're seeing like
crazy shit like that
well i don't know that whole story it's
wild is it it is wild the people that
were working there were instructed to
scrape the mold off of the top of the
jam like they it wasn't cooked and
stored the way that it was supposed to
be yes and people were getting really
sick
customers yes uh it was wild yeah i mean
food safety is pretty important you get
a lot of people safe really fast
um so i don't i don't know if she was
rushing it or was it it was just a lack
of experience really
my way works i know yeah i mean you
can't mess around with food in chemistry
like there's some pretty dangerous stuff
there some hard and fast rules when it
comes to salmonella bacteria fascialism
then we put botulism in our face yeah
right yeah i don't
i would never
how dare you comply
um and what do you do when you do you
take vacations are you can you ever take
time off so right before the pandemic i
felt like i was actually getting pretty
rude at it you know i'm like hey
relaxing yeah a little bit it wasn't
horrific
um
and then that whole thing changed
you know the last two years i probably
worked harder than
i had
prior
the last three years during the pandemic
yeah wow yeah but you because after you
were shut down you mean or one sick came
back so we pivoted right away when
chicago shut down two days later we were
back up and running with curbside pickup
wow
so never in my life people were just
walking down the street with balloons
yes
but
you know it was uh
i would have never thought that i'd put
plenty of food in a brown paper bag
and hand it to somebody and not have the
brown paper bag be edible yeah right
but it was wild yeah
and now that we're able to travel
i i hope to pick up some vacations like
where would you go on vacation
well now i feel like we've been deprived
right so i'm gonna go everywhere
i even wanted one of the places that
i've already been because i miss them so
much so
well now there's this craziness going on
in europe so
i don't know how soon i'll be able to
get back there but i would love to go to
paris i haven't been to paris in
10 years you go to paris what is your
first meal when you go to paris my first
meal if you're like
where is where do you go
well here's the other thing i don't even
know what's open in paris right right
you know um so my first meal probably
room service okay
um
but yeah i would i would really love to
go uh
to europe i would i would love to go
back to japan i love japan oh my god
it's so good
it's so incredible i like the uh
your dreams of sushi is one of my
favorite like i just watched that it's
just
i mean watching that documentary and
watching the the making the sushi just
the k like
is so uh i don't know my ocd discipline
you know the tradition
the repetition
life that they have to do is
to be able to have the discipline to do
that every day
is
pretty impressive right the meal that i
had in japan so i have a
a friend that's a chef
and he's like i'm gonna take you
everywhere i'm gonna show you tokyo
and on the last night we went into this
restaurant
and it was a pork restaurant
and i might find i like pig like pool
we'll have some barbecue or whatever
oh everything was raw
oh okay nope
but no not only was it raw no but the
meal was several forces wrong that
started out
with the most approachable
which was like raw pro shop
and it worked it's all the way all the
way down
the very last force
big vagina
brains eyes
river heart a raw
at the very end they put that down and
it was like the delicacy and i might
know
i'm not doing it
and he you know he's calling me names
and
tell me i was a chicken did he call you
a pussy
you know it's tricky because in you know
i went to vietnam i went to tokyo i
really struggle when i see on the menu
you know or
in
dog or shark yeah you know that's really
rough for me yeah whale like that breaks
my heart i had to leave vietnam early
because i just was like
i would go by
yeah you'd see dogs in cages outside
it's not everyone the place that i was
you know um and it was just really hard
to watch yeah but i know that you know
they look at us and are disgusted by a
lot of our customs like they're
mortified and horrified by the fact that
we put old people in nursing homes like
they think that's disgusting you know so
i always try to just go like i'm sure
there's things that we do to them seem
horrible but i just i that's something
that
what do they look at with us and go well
they eat that thing we would never eat i
don't i'm not sure
or like they look at us and they're like
oh those people are just fine getting c
pluses yeah you know what i mean like
they look they're disgusted by this this
is how you line up in an airport exactly
totally like they exactly like you know
so i always try to just go what do we do
that they find completely probably a lot
i wonder what it's like being a chef
over there have you been in a kitchen
over there and seen yeah yeah and again
kind of like zero right they practiced
for
10 years before they've even touched a
piece of fish right so there is a lot of
that
that hires you that there's no shortcuts
and we're not trying to make any and you
don't you don't challenge the elder
right
if you're in the airport
you're in the food court what are you
getting
anywhere out here
it's a pennsylvania airport
o'hare
i'm definitely going to
rip bayless's frontera
okay
the tortoise and everything they're
really good
cincinnati
i've got an indian's pretzel a cinnabon
and actually i'm probably going to burst
your mcdonald's yeah
i was going to say just as you sometimes
like i've i've found like i'm like
sometimes when it comes to pizza
nothing's better than a day old domino
so it's just
microwaved and just like
i grew up on a little caesar so
where do you find like like you know to
me like you know in la we've got um
what's the fancy chinese restaurant
nope that's hilarious though
who what's the one the fancy can you
just mr chow mr chow yeah okay it's
obviously incredible i i mean as someone
i didn't grow up going to fancy
restaurants and stuff you know we did
like cheesecake factory it was our big
christmas that you know whatever and and
you know going to that i kind of was
like
you know what i almost would prefer to
just go down to
you know chinatown
yeah like are there any foods where
you're like this just needs to stay kind
of
uh
like that's the best version of this so
if you're gonna go get pizza are you
gonna go to like the fan are you gonna
go like i want to go to this hole in the
wall
that's where this food does best uh i am
not
first of all i don't like deep dish
pizza
i'm not a chicago deep dish person at
all
it's
like that to me it's it's because i
remember like going to pizza growing up
it was like the the deep dish pizza it
just means less cheese for everyone yeah
i'll i'll fuck with a cheese filled
crust right like that was a good
call okay that was the molecular
gastronomy yeah i fucked with it yeah
they they yeah
but yes that's just it's too much bread
i want more i
pizza like when i'm in new york i go to
prince street yep you know what kind of
pizza what's your pizza
i honestly just pepperoni that's it it's
simple yeah um what else uh like
like what's your nightmare you know like
what's your for me
for example
it's something a lot of people wouldn't
think of but if i go out on stage
and someone in the second row has on a
giant cowboy hat
i know that's something that no one else
would think is a problem but it's like
it's all i'm thinking about now everyone
behind you is just looking at a cowboy
hat
it's distracting it's not and you have
to say something and deal with it yeah
it's a it's something that only if
you've been doing it for a long time you
know is a problem you have to solve and
it's going to affect the quality of the
show
but no one would really know why the
quality of a show is being affected huh
little things that corrode the
experience
that only you would be able to kind of
know
but other people
would be like
it's just take some of the magic out but
only you could really identify it
man someone's phone going off somewhat
you know uh someone talking on their
phone during a thing like what are the
things that
well
the obvious and absolute worst is
if i can see somebody not enjoying their
meal
because what that does is
it makes me act different
in the dining room like we left the
dining room all the time and do the
dessert on the table right
and if i happen to go out there and i
see someone like making a face or
whatever
it it
then i don't want to talk to anyone it's
for me if i'm performing for 3 000
people if someone in the second row yeah
is kind of just like who knows maybe
they have a bad day or they're not
it's all i can think about that's it and
then i have to stop and go like oh so
everyone else that's laughing they're
wrong but you're right like they're they
don't like right all i can think about i
know it drives me nuts that like
perfectionism but that's also why you're
you because
of that right perfectionism but that one
person shouldn't be able to drain that
confidence out of you like that
right
but at the same time like it's like it's
part of the reason i think that that you
probably you know you are where you are
because you were
your attention to detail yeah and one
thing being the tiniest bit off made you
so fucking
frustrated that you had to get it
perfect next you know i remember
food for this right and it's any sort of
journalism that was
you know fatigued oh man opening night
of millennia
we had the food for the new york times
come in
and at that point 2005
they never went outside of new york also
isn't there something with food critics
where restaurants never know when
they're going to come
well we didn't know he was coming but we
knew as soon as he sat down okay and he
wrote a kind of
shitty review
and that that was tough
because then you're like no this is
nobody's talking about or i know that
was right right so one of my favorite
quotes so many quotes are attributed to
oscar wilde and there's no way this
motherfucker did all these quotes but
he said critics are people that go
to the battle site where the war was
fought
and they shoot the survivors
i just kind of love that because it's
like
and i have this in tv when people get
you know bad reviews from critics it's
like
i don't believe that you should be able
to be a critic of television or movies
until you've made tv or movies you know
how hard it is you know what you're
looking at who
you have to have run a restaurant
and now you can be a food critic right
i suppose that's
nuts yeah
but they're supposed to be
the voice of their readership
mm-hmm so in theory
if you're the fifth writer for the new
york times you're supposed to
talk about the experience as
somebody that reads the new york times
food section right but also critics they
can't give great reviews every week or
people they have to go like i gave a lot
of good ones now i have to get you know
some people don't think i'm playing
favorites or just oh actually it's
probably it's more prevalent to
hand out really harsh reviews yes
because it's the only way that they're
relevant because now with twitter and
yelp like yeah i'd rather hear from just
the people yeah
right that ate there
you know i'm not comparing this to
you know i don't to
900 of the restaurants i've reviewed i
just want to know what yeah and all the
people in the industry now that i talked
to um
after the survival mode of the pandemic
all of the accolades now
nobody really seems to care right
and i wonder what that's gonna do i
think for me i'm learning at least in my
field
the thing that matters the most now is i
feel we're back to word of mouth
yeah you know people have lost trust in
the media lost justin people trying to
sell them too hard on stuff right so if
i see if if i'm gonna go to the movies
this weekend you know if i've seen 50
billboards for a movie or you know it's
trending on twitter i'm just going why
are they spending so much money on
promotion this also almost feels fishy
it got amazing reviews you got to go see
it if emily says i saw this it was great
i'll go see it yeah the person that you
trust opinion to me the word of mouth
matters so much more than all of the
press and stuff and the same with
critics i think that it's you know
so hard for anyone to give a shit with
some like rich white out of touch guy
that didn't even pay the fucking bill at
the end
right i want to know what like uh but
you look around in tomatoes
yeah
sometimes you'll see this but that's
like yeah you know that's something you
sort of go to but for me
yeah someone i trust opinion is way more
valuable to me than critics and critics
to get any attention or clicks now they
have to be
negative and shitty yeah yeah i think
that's it it's really exciting when
people want to complain about social
media or limp it's like it's been a
fucking miracle because you know
movies tv restaurants are now not their
success or
how they're perceived as not rest or in
the hands of some fucking idiot that
couldn't do what we do
right so now you're going to be a judge
of what we do right because you couldn't
do what we do you didn't put in the
hours and now you're just going to sit
back and be a judge
now it's like with you know insta i mean
you go to the olynya hashtag thing and
it's like all these incredible people
are going to do that before they're
going to read some review of some
fucking right
that drives me nuts i don't know it
drives me insane because they're coming
in to cr to look for problems they
already knew
you already knew they probably already
wrote the article and this is this is a
magical experience like this is a
you know coming in to he's coming he's
going to work yep
going and then i think the truck we're
the perfectionists the people that want
to make magical experience we're the try
hards yeah you know and he's probably
like you know who i
like you don't mean someone that's not
trying so hard like you know i don't
know that just drives me nuts because i
always want to put on a great show i
want like you know to give people the
best night of their life and i and i
give a lot but sometimes if you give a
lot they're like
you get punished for being the straight
a student yeah or something
yeah and they have to buy in too
you know how can how can somebody like
that
walk into that experience and genuinely
want to be
moved right do they want to hear the
story yeah you know yeah you can pick
apart the sexualities right right oh
this wasn't hard enough for this or that
but
it's not really even about that
i feel sorry for that person because
it's like it's you've taken away the
ability the impish
joy of being able to like experience
something magical because you're just
reducing it to like i have to write a
thing and you know a friend of mine
who's a showrunner pointed out to me
because i'm seeing a lot of tv shows
unfairly getting dragged for being like
this is re-embedding stereotype like
just
woke bullshit
where he pointed out to me like they
can't like everything
or else it looks like they aren't
critics yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah they have
to assert their opinion yeah right they
have to like have some kind of
either keep people coming back
the haters coming back or so it doesn't
seem like they just like everything but
um
that drives me nuts but it seems like
that article really did hurt your career
yeah it was devastating no but
affect your success in any way i mean
you know but it's the kind of thing
where it's like
you just hurt my feelings dude i hope
you're happy yeah and my business
partner was like this is amazing we've
got the front page of the food section
new york times
you know there's no bad press and i'm
like no this is bad press he's like no
nobody's here no
don't look at the photos they'll read a
little bit they'll forget the bad stuff
and they'll be fine yeah i mean it's
like how long does it take to get into
linear three months
yeah and then so neck so the um
uh aviary yep right that's just
cocktails right that's what made you go
like i want to get in
do cocktails i felt like at the time
there was no progressive
mentality in cocktails there were still
you know pre-prohibition cocktails yeah
and i was like hey don't need smoke
coming off yeah they're just like
getting it because they do
so yeah um so yeah that was really it we
were like hey we have all this ip we
have all this stuff that we created with
food yeah that we can apply to cattle do
you drink no really no and so do are you
ever like uh
so do you just defer to someone and go
like well i mean
for sure we'll
come up with a drink but i don't
imbibe taking another break from grant
uh there's a podcast called life is
short if you guys like this podcast i
think you will love justin long's
podcast called life is short he chats
with celebrities actors musicians
artists and more about how they get the
most out of their life like how do we
make the most out of our time here on
earth how do we bring meaning to our
life's work and what is the best emoji
to use when texting obviously the
eggplant but these are the important
questions that will be asked on this
weekly interview podcast listen to the
life is short with justin long podcast
on apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app
that's smart and frugal and now we are
back to grant you got so successful so
young and i think that when someone
becomes successful really young but also
has done the work there's an opportunity
to
change dysfunctional systems just
because you're coming in with fresh eyes
are there any things where you were just
like
we should do this this way or you know
like
you know i think the big one was uh
the reservation system that my business
partner developed
i mean who would have thought that you
would pre-pay
wow for food
for dinner
like it was unthinkable like what people
were like well what if what the meal is
not good
i'm like what are you talking about you
know so that is something it was the
idea of pre-paying
it takes away the magic at the end when
the bill comes and someone has to like
think about it definitely that but the
way that she
told me about it he was like look we're
leaving money on the table like but
nobody
nobody buys the springsteen
concert they get
and their favorite sex
or their babysitter's handsome yeah and
they don't try to
get a refund from ticketmaster yeah
why is it any different
interesting and i'm like uh-huh yeah
you're right
so that was sort of revelatory
that is fascinating which by the way you
know who wanted to come by but couldn't
because his daughter has um her first
school play as sebastian maniscalco oh
yeah was gonna come by and say hi and i
made me think of this joke he used to
have of how
when you're on a date and you get the
bill at the end
and it just ruins the night it ruins the
whole night right because you're looking
at that and it's like who ordered the
salmon and what that's the last thing
you remember right
yes so that was pretty that was pretty
industry disrupting i would say that's
fascinating it's the same thing with you
we're just talking about a hotel we both
like to stay at
it's all incl it's already paid for yeah
and everything in the minibar you've
already paid for so you're not going how
much is this should i have it should i
don't know you know right and it's just
like everything in here i'm allowed to
drink i've already paid for it i'm not
being nickeled and dying yes yeah i mean
you are but
at least i know
i'm not gonna check out at the end and
go what the fuck the water was eight
dollars and then it ruins undermines the
entire trip absolutely just fuck me up
front yep yep
so i know what's going on um so you
don't do a lot of podcasts no you're
very mysterious enigma why not are you
because in a time where
you know chefs are now like
people can't get enough of chefs yeah
like right chef tv shows cooking shows
are the biggest thing
like are you kind of like okay i didn't
sign up to be forward-facing person that
talks a lot is it something that comes
naturally to you is it something that
makes you feel uncomfortable not
uncomfortable i just feel like
i have a hard time uh
i was i feel like i have nothing
interesting to say
that's hilarious i do i don't know it's
strange
like everyone wants to come shoot
whether it's like you know all these
chef shows on netflix and all these
shows that you've been on like so like
the the chef stable one the documentary
um i became good friends with the
director and
that was like really well done
they were there in the restaurant for 14
days straight and um
that sort of stuff i enjoy
i like being able to tell the story i
don't like sensationalizing mm-hmm so a
lot of the cooking shows are very
scripted
and you just lose
control
you don't have control
and i just i don't
find that very genuine
podcast i just i don't know i've only
done maybe
three mm-hmm nobody asked me
well it is you're very intimidating the
only reason i ask you is because we work
together yeah 50 and i remember being in
a car with you and you being so
lovely and excited i mean chefs scare
the shit out of me especially the big
ones they're very terrifying you know
and
so it's like when people say to me like
comedy is like that's so hard and i'm
like you know what you do is what
i really am like i could never fucking
do that like i am so blown away with
your your
ability to
make these it's just it's so emotional
like taste is so emotional like it's
it's performance plus science plus math
like nostalgia nostalgia instinct going
this needs to go out right now yeah and
this has you know it's it's the same you
know in comedy jokes have expiration
dates you know of like okay that charlie
sheen reference like that's not gonna
hit anymore or you're doing a joke
that's like and the russians it's like a
joke that was funny about russia two
weeks ago it's a different joke now yeah
so you have to understand what's going
on in the zeitgeist in the context a
joke that got a huge laugh a week ago
might get a uh
today based on what happened in the news
you know so
that's something that i i have the
instincts to know how to deal with but
you know you just i'm just obsessed with
with skills that are impossible
to build unless you've just put in the
fucking time
yeah but also do you
find yourself
for me if i have first a dish
that i know works every time hot potato
folks tale yep
at some point i'm just like i don't find
any satisfaction from doing this
and then i just take it off the menu yep
i assume it's the same with you for me
it's tricky because like musicians
the the audience wants to hear the hits
so
we're going to madonna i want to hear
like a virgin she's probably sick of
playing oh my god can you imagine no
right
and and
so like my business partner would say to
me
just through the hypothetical and i'm
like
and he's like
the rolling stones you go to the concert
you hear let it bleed that's just the
way it is they've been sitting for 50
years and i'm like yeah but i don't want
to do it anymore
i can't get it up for this thing you
know and for me yes that's
you know as a comedian i know
that a joke that is a a joke
that works every fucking
time if i do it but i'm not feeling it
or i'm bored of it or i don't think it's
funny anymore it's not gonna yeah it's
not gonna hit the same way sometimes a
new joke that's not even well crafted or
to me
perfect yet like well constructed is
gonna kill because i think it's so funny
i believe that so much because the same
way in the restaurant if we put a new
dish on that we're all like super
excited about
but if we were saying opening night yeah
it's not the first time you serve it
never the best time yeah right it'll
always get better
but that palpable energy
like when the server puts it down and
describes it and
you know if i happen to be out in the
dining room you know i'm doing something
and the election oh yeah they feel it
yeah
and it's tricky like when do you
like when do the eagles go you know
we're not playing hotel i know you love
it yeah but we also have to you know and
to me i realized okay i worked for you
guys yeah you know like people would say
i'm gonna give you what you want but
then also there's like in my last
special even said i was doing this joke
that it killed 50 percent of the time
sometimes it was hillary and i was you
know this one's for me yeah it makes me
laugh so i'm gonna leave it in
you know because it's just i do that
if i what's what's something that you're
like this kills fifty percent of the
time or this is like polarizing um i'm i
did a dish
uh my food taste
that
a
was
that had
all of the five
senses on the palette
represented
and it was that's like charlie in the
chocolate factory the meal yeah it was
exactly like that
and
people didn't like it
but i liked it
because i couldn't taste and i was like
sure
you want you want taste this is taste
this is the five things that you can
perceive here it is
and the fact that it wasn't delicious
i found funny do you believe in the
clearing the palette thing between
is that a thing it is a thing the sorbet
or whatever sherbert's what's this
just have a imagine grant comes down i'm
like what's the difference between shore
bay and sorbet yeah sherbert
let's get down to the real science
dividing america today
um you just have a sip of water
in between yeah
it's not that hard
and you know
you have some diet coke it's got a lot
of acid in it right
do you believe in the whole like pairing
wine with a thing
i i believe
i believe that there are certain things
that will absolutely
flash but
i don't necessarily believe in
it being so nuanced that
this is the perfect beverage to go with
this dish yeah
there's a simple size you don't want to
have a dessert wine with
spaghetti and but mayonnaise
what is that yeah spaghetti spaghetti
and bolognese delicious but
if you really like sweet mine
and you want to sit there with a glass
of ports yeah while you're having your
spaghetti
vote for it
who cares getting shamed for pairing the
wrong drink with everyone's like i think
so
such white trash because i'm just like
can i get a red wine and some fish
they're like wow yes there's nothing
wrong with that there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that
what are some like uh
uh things that annoy you in the culinary
world that are like
you know like as a comedian is like
you know look i'm so happy for everyone
that's getting successful at 20 on
tick-tock for you
like you'll find out soon enough that
performing on stage for an hour a
different skill anything that you're
just like
oh this thing of the avocado toast
fucking thing
everyone's making feeding
half the people i know are like i gotta
get home i gotta go feed my starter and
you're like why are why is everyone
making why does everyone need to be
mormon all of a sudden right you know
after the panda makeout you know is
there anything that you're just like oh
i'm so sick of hearing about that or
well
the tistox recipes i find very
interesting
because they're largely
false i there was one the other day
uh a friend of mine
sent me a link to the stick tag where he
was like this is gonna blow your mind
it's a new way to cook bacon
and i'm like okay
send it to me by the way send the
cooking bacon thing to your friend with
the raw pork restaurant right right yeah
so they put the water in the pan then
they put the bacon in and then you put
it down until the water evaporates
and it's supposed to make perfect bacon
and i'm like i didn't even obviously i
didn't do it because i'm like that
doesn't work yeah
the water pulls out all the salt all the
smoke you're just left with pork it
doesn't taste like bacon
well i mean you know
all that stuff like
this time is
probably not the most trusted source are
you on there i am not you've i have an
account
but i've never posted on that
i mean you could be doing the real real
on there you think yeah i was going to
do on tick tock because i it took me a
long time to figure out like i'm not
going to do dancing i'm not going to
transition i'm not doing lazy
cheerleading like i'm not how would i do
this without embarrassing myself because
this is obviously a platform that
matters and like you know um
and i'm basically just doing like the
life hacks that i've learned and one of
them actually is cooking related
just
i learned from my aunts in virginia to
cut a cake the easiest way to cut a cake
is use dental floss okay yeah that's
smart little things like that that are
just like
things that i learned i actually learned
something
off with safety from
samantha
where if you're
cutting cherry tomatoes in half
you put a plate down
put your cherry tomatoes on there stack
another plate on top
and then take the knife and go through
it that way that's genius my mind was
mind-blowing yeah i was like how did you
learn this your girlfriend your
girlfriend how did you know this huh how
did you she learned that first time
hilarious so i'm like how did you just
blew my mind how where did you learn
that she goes oh someone said that's the
other family because sometimes it's like
you're so good at being trained to cut
little tiny tomatoes
no one would ever present that solution
to you they don't teach that in culinary
school she was how do you do something
like one at a time
that is so fun i know moron
my boyfriend recently he makes like pies
a lot okay and
he has a little device i just didn't
know about it that's i'm like cutting
apples for the pie and he just pulls out
a thing that's like a circle that just
you i don't know it's like a shark tank
device or some shit where you just cut
them all at once and i'm like yeah it
blew my mind that's so fuss little
things like that yeah cut dental floss
because you know the average person
cutting a cake it's like a fucking mess
and it ruins the cake yeah you know
whatever yeah
so just dental floss
that's one i grew up let me ask you like
you know like
southern food like i sort of the only
food i know how to cook and make is like
southern food that is probably your
nightmare like shepherd's pie chip beef
gravy sausage gravy
shit that was
made basically to put in the fridge and
eat for the rest of the week or that was
just
like shepherd's pie i believe was just
like we have a bunch of leftovers let's
make a fucking thing out of it yeah
we have shit beef on the menu right now
amazing because i think people tend to
like dismiss southern cuisine a little
bit i don't like ofra
okay i don't know if we're a fan i okay
how dare you my okay so my mother is
from a place called sherman texas okay i
used to
so fried okra was the main food
i was responsible for cutting the okra
okay and when you cut okras you know oh
yeah this gelatinous viscous
clear semen snot
comes out
it's disgusting but i guess when it's
fried with some ketchup
it might as well be anything else yeah i
just don't like it yeah is it the
preparing or just the flavor of it
you know that music
yeah it is i guess because i grew up on
it it was like the main thing we ate in
texas when we first dinner we'll have
oprah with sewers yes
we'll do like a double dare thing of
like i'll you eat okra i'll have sea
urchin let's do this
um but uh that's fascinating to me like
my version of that is honeydew
yeah
i don't get it i don't see the point if
it's not cantaloupe or watermelon like
honeydew is the most trash fruit it
really is trash it ruins everything
because you can never find a ripe one
if you had a really like if you threw it
in your backyard
it's and it was sweet and nice and yeah
my grandmother in texas had a cantaloupe
farm so when you grow up eating
delicious cantaloupe right yeah like
honeydew and you're like this is just
garbage chocolate yeah it tastes like
cardboard it just it's just like it
tastes like weird like like strippers
perfume
what is that it's like the filler yeah
fruit i don't know the fruit salad
it just ruins all of it yeah it taints
the whole thing
the pineapple
cantaloupe the cherries yeah i don't
need this bridge and tunnel ass honeydew
fucking up
my food you know but i love uh i love
like the nitty-gritty of stuff like that
um and so what i'm just curious like
what are your like biggest indulgences
like with food like things that you love
where you're like
you know
that you'll be like i want to create
this like
or sorry create like that you're like
for example like um i happen to love um
like saffron like any kind of like when
i go to arizona uh any they have these
like popsicle stands that are you know
uh mexican icy popsicles what is it
called pileta palette is that what it's
called and it'll be like
like
cinnamon lime like it'll be some crazy
fucking combination where you're like
lavender saffron yeah like there's no
way this will taste good and you're like
this combination is weirdly incredible
like i
this is gonna sound crazy when i first
uh moved to la i didn't have any money
and i had like seven dollars in my bank
account i was in debt and i used to go
to a place called pink dot which is a
convenience store i used to get turkey
jerky okay and i would cover it in
maple syrup
and it was like to me
the most amazing combination
growing up my dad used to make peanut
butter and mayonnaise sandwiches
okay sounds insane but and then when he
made scrambled eggs he would put cream
cheese instead of regular cheese oh yeah
that's fine i'm used to like i love a
wild are there any like wild
combinations you're like trust me oh
there's some mild combinations that
we've done yeah um
let's see
mango and
bonito
was a weird one
you know sweet and fishy
do you find it first or do you just
stumble on it or are you like
do you have like days where like i'm
just gonna combine a bunch of stuff and
see what happens no
a lot of is epidemic where you're like
okay the salt will balance with the
sweet and you know so it's like pieces
of the puzzle like science background
yeah but
um
sometimes it's by smell
which is weird that is very weird yeah
like chocolate and soy sauce
yeah
very good together fascinating yeah
yeah
licorice
so i i happen to love my hers too
and there's a sap
that comes from an evergreen tree and
primarily in roots or like the
mediterranean
from mastic
mouth deck
and it is also used to
it's very sticky obviously it's a sap so
they use it over there to like
put shingles on roofs as well
and it has a very an industry
electricity flavor and i would when i
first tried it i loved it and i would
put it in a lot of dishes this is back
in like 2006. mastic high grade
construction adhesive yeah they used to
bond ceiling wall and floor tiles yeah
that's it plywood panels concrete
asphalt leather and fabric
so i i
used a lot of that and uh
people people didn't love it amazing it
has a very strong resource
and how important
is smell
and how good something tastes oh it's
huge it's everything right yeah
so back to that lasted you there's like
five things that your palate can
perceive
but the human nose and smell i think
it's like 900 smells
so you talked about mine right
when you pick up a glass of red wine you
swirl it smell it and you're like if
you're a mind nerve right you're like oh
i smell
black cherry and fig and coffee beans
what's in there yeah grapes
grapes just grapes it's all grapes
there's so hot no it's a leafy
like when people talk about wine i'm
just like
so
it's got a it's got an earthy i'm like
what does that mean what does earth even
mean i have a hard time even having
vocabulary to even understand and i'm
always like you guys are so full of shit
yeah so if you do have some wine then
you may say oh yeah this tastes like
cherries i'm like it's just good it's
good that's delicious that's all i know
but that's something from smoke
it's just grapes
right
and i guess there's also a
you know
for me when it comes like tasting food
and wine and stuff i'm so desperate to
be able to have the vernacular to talk
about it to be
i i i it's like to me you know the guy
that i'm dating is like he he you know
isn't you know we started dating a
couple years ago but he's introduced to
me this uh joy of eating that i never
have i work at night i don't get to go
to restaurants and enjoy sort of
culinary arts like i'm like eating a
half frozen hot pocket in a car and
eating a nutrigrain deep throating grain
bar on the way to the airport like it
was just that and as someone that you
know i i
this is no secret or anything but in my
you know teens and most of my 20s
struggled with eating disorders and had
a very sort of um
acrimonious relationship with food yeah
you know and so
now i'm sort of at a point where i'm
like
so comfortable with it i want to try
everything i want to make up for the
time i lost in terms of the joy of food
and
some of the best moments of my life
growing up were being with my aunts that
are southern that would you know cooking
and making southern cuisine and just
sort of
it's just so healing i mean food is just
the most healing
thing to cook with people to go to a
restaurant and be able to like you know
enjoy all these
senses and i think that when i lost my
sense of taste during covid
it really made me go like holy shit like
this is a
an art and a
therapeutic um
uh experience that i've not
capitalized on yeah you know yeah i
didn't really start appreciating it
especially after having eating disorders
and stuff which i was like i just want
foods that's fat free i was starving
myself
the idea of amazing food it was like all
i would see is like fat calories
whatever right and now i'm trying to
make up for lost time and my boyfriend
is like such a food experience person
and so i'm kind of catching up on all
this maybe a hint
a little tip
about wine talking about wine
so if it's a red wine
anything that is
dark in color
and with fruit you have to cut it open
so if it's a red apple
you cut it open it's white that goes to
the white line
anything that's dark purple red
that way
you can say oh this smells like face it
smells like cherries it smells like
grapes
anything that you're
evaluating white wine
pineapple grapefruit lemon
all that stuff just mix it up that's so
i'm like i'm taste lychee nobody
nobody's nobody should ever say no you
don't because you always say yes i do
that's so that is what i smell
just make it up you will slow it down
you will absolutely shut it down that is
so funny
anything cause all the wine stuff is so
intimate it makes me feel stupid but
it's just but it's just be full of shit
tastes like honeydew yeah
yeah how do you do it tastes like a
lychee acai berry
[Music]
not like that right you know
honeydew of age right
honey do illegal age cut grass not just
grass no this is like a saffroni because
that's the thing you can just the more
so
if you just say like nutmeg you're good
tastes like um
contaminated water it tastes like
mercury
what is the
over-under on
the fish thing so a friend of mine used
to in a restaurant and told me something
that may or may not be true which was
like
he was i was like we were at a
restaurant i was like oh my god let's
order like the chilean sea bass yeah he
was like it's all the same shit it's a
trash white fish and chile and sea bass
that shit's made up like no that's not
sure which is there no but he revealed
that he was just a crook and that
sometimes they put trash fish in oh that
that may happen right there was a new
york times article on how some
restaurants lie about the fish
yeah and mark it up like crazy and i
started being like
oh i thought
like chilean sea bass this is here's a
great story in that regard i know of a
restaurant this is a long time ago
you ever heard of the fish orange ruffy
yes
okay
so i remember
the owner of this restaurant that would
take cod filets
soaked it in tomato juice
and serve it as orange ruffy and i
always thought
oh he's trying to make it orange with
the tomato juice come to find out orange
ruffy isn't orange
so i don't know what the hell he was
doing
but he thought he was pulling a fast one
on everyone
he wasn't that is fascinating so what
you have an orange roughy story well
that was like
she lit up you're like yeah
okay
we go get
no i think that was one of the ones in
the article in the new york times
article about fish that are uh often
by charlatans
yeah you're bullshit i mean to me i
think the average person would be like
if you tell me it's orange ruffy yeah
and i'm already invested in this
experience i'm gonna enjoy it but it was
sort of but is there a little bit of a
um
you know
concern about like the mercury and
oceans and stuff do you like follow up
on that yeah for sure i mean we have to
be aware that's part of our
responsibility as chefs i think and you
know there's certain
causes and organizations that we support
to try to you know make the planet
better
um i don't allow it to
pay attention to it
but i don't
i probably always have free acidity
because because here's the thing for me
it's like when people like okay don't
eat a ton of fish eat
fish once a week i'm going i don't want
a linea next to not serve it
when i eat it it's going to be there
yeah you know what i mean yeah for sure
it doesn't mean stop serving it if
you're the best at serving and it just
means i'm going to save it and only have
it when i'm with right you know
yes
and i haven't seen it yet but i
while i was watching that i was eating
sushi guess what me too
oh my god that's so much better yeah no
you know okay yeah
that's um
it was that intentional i mean you know
yeah but i didn't i didn't know that
they were gonna tell you not to eat fish
i didn't know it was gonna be that yeah
i didn't either
it's a documentary that highlights the
damaging effects of fishing on the
world's ocean so at the very they go
through it on at the very end they're
light so the best thing you can do is
just naughty fish and i'm like
okay so my thing is like hey how's it
already here how could we shut down like
long john silvers and brothers right
yeah but we keep you know what i mean it
doesn't mean everybody stop it means
just the shitty one stop you're wasting
it i mean it's like
you know the shitty ones i mean it's
like
you know that's like the thing with like
in my field going no one can
make jokes about this it's like no just
the people that
are doing it that in a mindless cheap
way the people that are the artists that
are going to do something incisive and
thoughtful right they can do it but this
like across the board
thing is just
throwing the baby out with the bathroom
that's right what do you do do you have
any like hobbies are you just aw
are you just always
i don't have any hobbies
i i feel i'm embarrassed to say that i
find that some of the most
high-performing legendary people like
you it's just
i wish i did but any hobby i've ever
taken on i have to either turn it into a
business yeah or i'll just start writing
jokes about it and then going into my
job yeah i don't even know what it would
be if i if i had time
i don't even know what it would be
well i'm not i'm i don't know no i'm not
gonna go cause
it's just it's it's one of those things
where it's like i constantly struggle
with going like okay if i want to be the
best at what i do yeah as this
overachiever perfectionist whenever i'm
doing a hobby i'm kind of just either
feeling like my inner monologue is like
you're falling behind yep you know
you're wasting your time
and it doesn't it's not relaxing because
i'm like well now this is gonna mean i'm
just gonna have so much more work
tomorrow because i was trying to like
relax
and then the whole time i'm kind of
secretly just working on the other thing
yeah people don't people will ask me all
the time like
how did you come up with that or
you know young program students will be
like how do we you know
be like through someday and
the answer is really unsatisfying just
work 24 hours a day practice
this is like everything else right your
social life's going to take a hit your
family life's going to take a hit i was
just telling someone who who's you know
younger and wants to do what i do and i
was like okay but you're not gonna be
done at six every day right you're gonna
miss your brother's wedding
yeah you're gonna miss christmas it's
just that simple
is there any blueprint like in our
industry it's really hard for someone
when they say like how do you get to do
what you do and you're like oh it's
different every time is there any
blueprint for for where i mean obviously
besides mass amount of skill and talent
but i mean like is there a certain
school that
you recommend for young chefs a certain
program like is there any blueprint the
most important thing is find a mentor
yeah yeah like when you were at french
laundry yeah right like you know truly
sure yeah but
you have to find somebody that you jive
with got it and can i just ask you about
just about that process because it's
like
everyone's like yeah i'd love to be
mentored in french laundry but they
choose
only what is that process like like i
know that the mentors i had i had to
tooth and nail like hound them that's
what i did wow
email them
fight to get their attention and then
they went oh shit you're gonna make it
with or without me and you're fucking
you have the moxie yeah i'm just gonna
bring you on because you're not gonna
stop hounding me so in 1996 i put a
handwritten letter in the mail
the real mail
every day
for 14 days straight yep
and finally chef keller called me he
goes okay here's the deal
you're either going to be really good
or you're already
fucking crazy yeah you're a stalker that
is like yeah gonna murder me in my sleep
so he let me come out and i got the job
and then you had to prove yourself yeah
yeah and but that's the other thing too
is
everyone's so caught up with
instagram and tic tac and tv that
when i was in that vision she was in
that kitchen every day
first one and last one out
and
those are the opportunities that are
pretty rare that you'd have to find you
can go work for a celebrity chef that
has a tv show
never a decision
so you're not going to learn from them
you know you have to be in the right
you're going to learn how to seek fame
instead of seek respect you're probably
not gonna learn that either because
they're never there
you know you have to find that young
person that still has again something to
prove yeah they're still driven
they're still chasing it and also going
like to me what you're like saying is
you know
the the older i get and the more
quote-unquote successful i get
the harder i end up working because i
think there's this thing in your head
that's like oh once i get to that level
i've shot four specials i'll be able to
work two hours it'll it actually again
you know you have to be prepared if you
want to be the greatest
i find myself working more and more
because not only is the bar higher but i
have to work harder to keep myself
interested so i don't get bored or or
plateau
and then you're dealing with all the
curve balls of just
new competition new like i'm like i've
mastered comedy and then tick tock comes
along and i'm like okay i have to
relearn this new skill
you know so it's just it it to me i was
listening to a podcast that you did
and you're talking about what it takes
and the work that it takes and the grit
and the that you still work six seven
days a week
and it's just like
you're the idea of i'm going to work
hard so one day i can just
coast
my mom it's crazy to me a month ago said
grant why are you working so hard still
like
and i go
i feel like i haven't done my best first
yet
and she was like what are you talking
about i'm like
i don't know i just feel like i have
more to give
you know yeah and i hope i do
um i'm like that too i'm like the best
is yet to come like and like acting or a
lot of jobs that
are sort of around me you know as a
comedian i'm like i mean rodney
dangerfield all these all these people
you start getting good in your 40s
that's when you're like oh shit like the
best is yet to come which is the best
feeling ever yeah she's like you have
all these athletes and what do you have
to prove who are you trying to prove it
to and i'm like myself
you know it's just
it's more about the chase right
for me it is at least what's your new
like thing you're like
nothing yet because the pandemic put
everything on pause
yeah
serving food to people that have lost
their taste yeah right is that a great
challenge here here's a bag yeah exactly
but you know
i'm optimistic no that seems very bad to
normal almost what is your favorite
cuisine gun to your head
if you're like i went to an island i can
only eat
besides elenia like
mexican venezuelan
french american
selection i have a lot of spicy food
because from the treatment okay the
radiation so
that sort of profuses like
a lot of
thai
mexican um
i love pasta love i love homemade pasta
what fascinates me is when you go to
italy and you think you have eaten a lot
of italian food in america and you go to
italy and you're like this is totally
this is i've never had italian food
before yeah it's like the pasta is like
that it's harder yeah it's there's it's
not full of cream right it's just like
olive oil and salt and yeah oh it's just
about quality ingredients not a bunch of
salt and shit yeah yeah and then so i
just i'm fascinated by that like if five
your five favorite restaurants i'm
putting on the spot
yeah just in general yeah they still
have to be open
no no
french fries
yes percent
of louie in spain
closed
um
this little farmhouse that i have no
idea
what it was called but it was a a bite
to her through destiny
that i randomly got on and we stopped
off there and this grandmother was
putting a brick on top of a chicken
that was magical wow
that's my fifth one
there's a restaurant in new york that um
serves buddhist
cuisine
so oh vegan
i just appreciate what they can do with
all my vegetables pretty cool that is
fascinating yeah
when you go home tonight what are you
gonna eat
well you're gonna be at the hotel yeah
well actually going over to a friend's
house so
we'll see what they prove me i love that
song
all my friends know that
i'm pretty relaxed when it comes to food
and then do you have like any sort of
i'm obsessed with just sort of like the
kind of
you know philosophy that someone lives
by like it's my instinct to ask you like
you know because is someone that has
become so successful based on their
instincts you know like you again you
can't teach instincts it's okay do you
have any
sort of like i always ask people about
like red flags like when you meet
someone and you're gonna decide whether
you're gonna be friends with them or not
date them whatever it is like what is a
a red flag for you in people i feel like
especially the famous person that people
always want might want something from
you i
whether this is
good or not
um
if a new a person that's applying for a
job loss in the back door of the
restaurant so we require everyone to do
a two-day tryout
so we look at their resume we vet them
that way we invite them to come in and
work for two days so we can actually
watch them hook right
as soon as they walk in the back door
i'll evaluate them and say they're gonna
make it they're not you can tell right
away yeah i'm like that with comedians i
know if someone's gonna make it or not
based on
is there any tell you can share like
that we would get i mean honestly just
the way they walk in
if they come in too confident that's a
problem okay if they come in
to sheepish right that's the problem i
don't know it's hard to do this one yeah
so someone comes up to me in the hallway
a comedian who's just starting out and
goes
hey if they're a little bit like i know
you're busy i just
i'm a comedian and i was just wondering
if you had any advice for me i always
say i don't need to give you the advice
the fact that you came up to me and
asked means you're already gonna make it
just keep working be yourself work
harder than anyone but the fact that you
went oh i'm going to ask someone that
knows more than me yeah
and you're not going well i know fucking
everything i don't need to ask anyone
that's a problem i always say you're
already gonna make it yeah you don't
need to ask me anything just keep
working your ass off yeah you know i can
tell the way they approach me i can but
so i know what you mean yeah there's
just something that you can suss out
right away which is not like overly
confident and arrogant and entitled but
also not
humble in a way that's not apologetic
and cheapest to where you're not going
to be able to stand up for yourself all
right you know what i can't stand is
when people ask you a question and you
know they know the answer just to seem
like they're they want to engage they
want to like you know they want to go
like look at me being the straight a
student yeah i'm asking happens in the
kitchen that's a huge thing
or someone will ask you something just
to go like i'm i'm deferring to you and
i'm they won't have a dialogue or
whatever yeah i hate it
i tend to really know those people
that's so fascinating yeah i just you
just put your finger on something that i
realized because i'm like oh and now i
have to go through the performance of
answering something which you already
know just so that i know you know just
so i clock you and you in your because
you need
me to think that you're a straight a
student yeah
or conversely if someone
doesn't know something and they pretend
they do
so my thing is i will never be mad at
you if you don't know but if you pretend
you know
and you jeopardize the team because then
when someone does genuinely not know
something and asks then when you do know
something i can trust you yeah that's an
immediate termination in the kitchen is
if somebody
knowingly puts something out or tries
that they know is wrong maybe they try
to cover it up because they don't want
to look stupid or like they don't know
they might be embarrassed they don't
want to get reprimanded i'd rather you
just ask and admit you don't know and
they try to snitch it out
immediate termination
like what would one of those things be
what's that like what's an example of
that relax i mean i hate to use it again
but the hops are for potato yeah
they slide in a hot pocket
they too everything's cold
they give you more potato more potatoes
they just throw in a tater tot
there's a problem
and you know
occasionally back in the day i would
walk over and feel the
spear on top
and if it wasn't
so hot that i couldn't touch it
and they knew sometimes it would just be
room temperature it's a big problem
there was a lot of more potato more
potato juice
i love that stuff
yeah the last thing i'm going to let you
guys i know you have
what is your favorite thing to make even
this day like i have favorite jokes i
love telling like what's your favorite
thing to make
for myself or someone else
because that's there's a difference
there i feel like
first both for yourself and then someone
else yourself is
cinnamon toast crunch yeah no myself is
probably an omelette
um
[Music]
i love eggs and there's something about
coconut omelet that most people take for
granted to do an omelet really well is
here's the thing it might be the only
thing i'm great at cooking yeah and you
know what drives me nuts this egg white
omelette
if you're gonna eat an egg white
omelette why eat an omelette right am i
an asshole no
what were you gonna say to to do it
while you up to what
before it just requires a lot of
patience and you know skill
people rush it the pan's not hot enough
do you flip it
uh
kind of yeah
i mean how do you kind of flip it yeah
it's a little bit i just have a
like a little system where i can sort of
jigger it and get it perfectly over but
i tip the pan a little bit yeah that's
fine it's sort of the only thing i know
how to cook because if you fuck up
um if you fuck up a fried egg enough
times you have to learn how to make it
online well because i was just trying to
do it
right
um
and then for other people i like
making them
birthday days
for other people
what's the number i i refuse
to celebrate my birthday i don't really
do it
but i really enjoyed making people
birthdays what's your
go-to whatever flavor they like
it's just a nice gift yeah you know
i
i used to
i will fuck up a sheet cake
like it's nothing just like a sheet of
vanilla on vanilla cake it's like a
person that's like a chocolate person
a vanilla chee cake
is like
unbelievably good i like chocolate with
vanilla buttercream that's my
that's what my mom used to make me for
my birthday so there's a nostalgia oh
yeah for sure what's your ice cream
currently
peanut butter chocolate having us wait
because everyone so we you have a
current for what most people have an ice
cream flavor
that's
i've i used to be a ben and jerry's like
a couple of flavors to ben and jerry's
i've rotated you know what i used to be
a mint chocolate chip only bluebell mint
chocolate chip a bluebell is a texas
brand
nothing else
mint chocolate chip was my shit okay and
maybe it was my dad's favorite ice cream
so maybe there's a nostalgic thing and
now i'll fuck up strawberry ice cream
and coffee coffee i like as a kid i'm
like
fluffy coffee was before the peanut
butter chocolate
for a couple months yeah i once said out
loud
mint does not belong in ice cream
and that's a wrap
i will see you in court
mint chocolate is i'm of i'm a weirdo
with weird combinations yeah i'm like a
chocolate covered bacon bitch i'm like a
red pepper chocolate bar bitch yeah like
uh
you know one of those
we i'll put potato chips
in a hamburger like i'm uh
oh yeah i'm like a one sauce on eggs
bitch
you know it's an a1 sauce oh no
urchin what i love a1 don't ruin it so
oh yeah what sardines babies anchovies
oh
that's so wild because my story is that
i don't like sardines cause i'm always
like in caesar's salads i'm like good
the sardines off but i guess i love them
yeah i would eat a one sauce i would
just deep throat it with like a like a
beer bong funnel yeah
in the south heinz 57 and a1 is a big
deal yeah what is your number one like
kind of like that's a trashy like if i
put ketchup on eggs people are like
you're trash no i love ketchup and ice
thank you yeah and i also like ketchup
on hot dogs but you're not supposed to
do that in chicago
chicago there's a lot of you so many
moves
so many rules about food in chicago
what's your number one like like
like if if you made someone a meal
what's the number one if they put a
condiment on it you'd be offended like
i don't how do i defend or is it just
salt
that would probably piss me off yeah
like if you served me a beautiful meal
what would be the most defensive thing i
could put on so i love songs too and
um
if anything i would season heavy on the
soft so if they reach for the salt i
would be better yeah you're like you
have tongue cancer yeah and so you
should go to your own colleges yeah
you're not well you might think you're
sad
mentally yeah
where are you on relish what's your hot
dog
i loaded up
yup yeah i loaded up
um mustard relish
ketchup go for the works yeah chicago
dog
yeah yeah
you like you're very i think i find that
people that are the most skilled in what
they do
sort of honor or appreciate just the
basics
of something and just quality
ingredients i made a first of clear hot
dog once bite size crystal clear hot dog
yeah i remember that you did the pie
that was crystal yeah yeah yeah yeah
which by the way pumpkin pie my new
obsession is i want to do a party for
remember those jell-o molds in the 50s
that i had like shrimp in them and like
meat
isn't it wild that that was like just
something people served
at like weddings and stuff it was a
jello mold with meat in it ham oh yeah
yeah
ham remember those yeah did you put in
like shrimp cocktail in a jelly mold as
like a pie yeah
oh the 50s
wild wild
smoking while pregnant making their
shrimp jelly mold just like these guys
and then so um okay i'm gonna let you go
next time you're in l.a maybe we can do
a round two yeah
maybe we can do like a something with
sebastian and we can cook something or
have like a little weird cookie food i
always get asked to do these like
cooking competition shows and i always
say no because i'm like
comically terrible at cooking but i do
know a couple you never mind
my friends never mind a judge or like
there's
all these like cooking shows they're
like two celebrities have to cook
something
[Music]
you know whatever i do have a couple
next time i'll serve you the things i
came up on when you're grew up poor and
in the south the weird combinations that
at the time you just thought they were
like culinary delicacies and you realize
it was just oh we were poor and we had
to just put those things together
baloney and something yeah
mayonnaise and peanut butter sandwiches
yeah okay i look back and i'm like oh
that was like a culinary delicacy last
last last thing okay
a friend of mine is now uh you know a
father and and um uh his kid is old
enough to be selling girl scout cookies
my friends are old enough to have kids
what is your number one because i i
pride myself on being able to meet
someone and know them and know what
their girl scout cookie is did i not
guess that yours was the shortbread the
tree foil yeah
sickening
it used to be the tag along but as i
matured it was but i know yours is not
then meant because mint you're none of
them i bet you're a tag along guy peanut
butter hold on no no no no no really
i know those i'd have to put in the
fridge oh i loved it because you love
peanut butter you know i love you i
should have known that
but you know that by the way girl scout
cookies are now
there's the gluten-free ones they can't
have peanuts and um yeah i just got all
my girl scout cookies and i'm like these
are not the fucking ones we grew up on
where's the gluten where are the fucking
peanuts like wait they have regular ones
don't they they have
just complaining about childhood
fundraising i would like to cancel the
new girl scout cookies
i would not have bought them knowing
they had the peanut butter ones didn't
have nuts in them anymore yeah right
they've had to like course correct
i'm like if your dork ass kid can't eat
a taco when he doesn't believe in food
allergies don't ruin it for the rest of
us that was like the only good part of
my childhood like you're not taking the
peanuts out of my fucking
girl scout cookies how dario
um
what an honor
thank you
thank you this was great what a pleasure
i just
sorry next time of course i would love
it
i know the next time sebastian will come
yeah next time we'll dazzle you and me
and two comedians will make the greatest
chef alive a meal
i love it and then you can do stand up
for us yeah oh no no no
what a pleasure this is i mean i'm sure
you guys already have it the linea um
coffee table book is i just
it's it's uh
it's a lot
it's a lot yeah you do look at that and
you're just like oh that took so much
work and time no i look at that i go
i know a couple of those recipes don't
work
don't worry no one that buys this yes
they're not actually yeah don't worry it
belongs on the coffee this is just porn
yeah exactly this is just porn um okay i
love you i am these very awkwardly uh
don't write elephants we love you guys
i'm gonna let you go bye bye thank you
grant
[Music]
[Applause]